[Music]
repeatedly
being
being fed a story and i'm listening for
the end of the story and i'm like okay
cool
what we can do after this you know i
mean like you tell and and literally i
learned that women just like to vent
it's not necessarily that you want to
have a conclusion to the end you just
like to vent but i'm looking at it like
okay cool that happened i'm going to fix
it like this
no but that's not i just wanted to talk
i just you just want to vent and i'm
like we don't communicate like that
literally like men don't communicate
that when we vent we vent to our other
men exactly and i'll vent to ish
i feel like we can't as well because you
know like that's time you know
yeah it's like we just communicate
differently i just think we need to stop
calling people misogynistic and
patriarchal all this kind of stuff and
just understand that we are wired
differently our brains are wired
differently i feel like it's a
generalization and you're also missing
out people who don't really conform to
any sort of gender norms and people who
aren't with someone who of an opposite
gender
and it's i don't know like you say women
do this women do that but
there are women who take the masculine
role in relationships to fill that role
and and men still have feminine energies
even if you want to deny and repress it
out of them they still have that
emotional body and just because they
don't necessarily have the same language
communicated it's still there and having
that emotional space to be vulnerable
with each other is so important in a
relationship you can't be vulnerable
with the person you're with
women like yourself are creating
feminine men that's my point you're
creating are you in my opinion you know
masculine men start wars so i'd rather
the feminine who doesn't start the war
if i'm honest women have started more
wars you yeah men start with a lot of
wars because of bloody women
because of women it's the men starting
it still though just because a woman has
caused it because a man you know helen
of troy and whatnot over beauty and all
that
but when you say that when you say you
want like the masculine the wit
sometimes the women take the masculine
world but that's not the natural not
necessarily with a man sometimes with a
woman as well
who's a bit more feminine so what if a
woman was transgender and she
transitioned then she's not naturally
like a man so then what is that bad
say that again so if a woman is feminine
a woman
uh whatever she maybe comes to
realization or she thought her whole
life and then she transitions and now
she's a man she's not a natural she's
not a man she's not she's she's a
biological female she's a biological
female it's not a man or female
doesn't
i mean you're right
i don't like the way you're saying it
from in the sense of she's like they are
they are biological females it's a
biological fact but you're talking about
this woman
is still there that's my validity is
still there what i'm saying is you think
that a man who doesn't behave manly is
wrong so a man who transitions to a
woman and then behaves
womanly is he wrong
is that is that bad for society is that
yes detrimental yes because
okay so if we flipped it right if we
said all the women in society now are
masculine and all the men now act
feminine how do you think society would
run
but it's not all men and women no i'm
just saying because you think it's okay
so i'm saying if you flip the rules if
you say all women act like men and all
men and black women how do you think
society is just
make it make sense to me if a biological
man yep became a woman became a you
can't become a woman but okay become a
woman
and then was behaving girly girly is
that wrong
what does that mean you said it but is
it wrong is it bad for sight is that
what you're saying it is well then your
views are just of course it's wrong
what's more silly what's more silly than
a man thinking that he's a woman
oh oh wow
silly like isn't it so completely
unfathomable it just wouldn't exist like
it exists and there's there's a spectrum
of gender right and people choose what
how
are you
feeling are you telling me that i can be
a woman i'm asking you
because there's a difference between
being male and female and being a man
and a woman get me out of here
masculinity debate is it not
conversations
are you a woman sorry it was it was a
friend
it's just a phrase yeah you're a woman
yeah so i could be you
no you couldn't be me because i'm a
person you're a person no but i'm saying
i could be your gender if yeah if you
wanted to change it yeah it's about it's
about masculinity and femininity people
can embody those roles it doesn't have
to be isolated
seriously
i feel like in the context of this
conversation we're talking about the
masculine and feminine roles and women
is a name for gender not sex that
someone can identify themselves with no
matter what because it depends on your
spirit your soul your mind your body
everything
how it works so how would you know if
someone's a male or a female i wouldn't
i would ask them you would ask them but
like could you make generalizations
about who's who you could have female
change no i couldn't yeah if you talk
about sex you're right but we talk about
men and women yeah and i would say based
on masculinity and femininity and if you
say that all women become men in terms
of fulfilling that masculine role that
masculine role is still oh i just
thought we couldn't generalize
one at a time guys people at home can't
hear i want everyone to hear so yeah
we'll get back to it sorry let me just
get back to this because this is
something that really like it grinds my
gears right you're telling me that as a
man who has been biologically born a man
with a penis and two testicles you're
telling me that i can be a woman
yes if you want to and you're and you're
now telling me also that a woman that
you with breasts a womb vagina you can
be a man if you're out there and you
want to you can yes you can no no no how
i think it could be a remix any way that
you want
you can get it done i'm a man yeah right
i know what is your man we've got three
men in here there's absolutely no way
you could be us we know that as men
there's no way you could be us i could
identify as a man i don't care what he
identifies you're not a man
cool it doesn't matter what you identify
as i feel a man so you going off on this
rant has told me that everything that
you've said before that was also
prejudice and bias and i really don't
respect any opinion that comes out of
your mouth i don't mind right
i'm gonna i'm gonna come at this from a
different level and say that i'm
actually non-binary and there are points
where i fulfill a feminine role and
there are points where i fulfill a
masculine role and i switch between
those energies and both feel equally um
comfortable to me and equally like i'm
not saying i could transition to a man
because i'm not transgender but it's
about the masculinity and the femininity
which transcends sex do you have a
vagina
yes i do
business
by this logic can i identify as black
yeah oh my god oh my god not completely
why not not the same thing why not
because it's it's it's it's racist it's
how i feel that's how i feel because
i feel grace
i can identify as pearl because i can
identify as a white woman that's silly
we don't know that it's something that
someone
said no it's intense we don't
distinguish if we talk about roles in
society we don't distinguish roles by
race we distinguish roles as apparently
by this conversation through you know um
through gender right sexuality um
femininity masculinity that's how we
define roles we don't do that by race
okay i identify as a dog then woof
i am afraid
right i'm african by genetics you're
female by genetics you know that right
right so so yeah there's no way in i'm
not a woman by genetics i'm a woman by
choice social construct
you're one by genetics you've got an ex
expert female female female social
constructs uh
yeah biology all right so tell me what a
woman isn't
are you also a woman is someone that
says i am a woman
wow
um i also think you're
everyone's talking in the binary is that
that you can either be a man or a woman
or you can't be like in between there's
in between where like you can be like oh
god willie but i really am feminine and
i love
typically feminine things and
you know i want to address a feminine
way that doesn't it may not even
necessarily mean that you want to
transition or whatever you could just be
a bit of a girly man do you know what
you just said you just said as long as
you say what you are you are that yeah
but listen
when i'm she wants to define when i'm
with a woman right i fulfill a more
masculine role like that's just kind of
a natural energy with a man i fulfill a
more feminine role it's just how i
naturally switch between the two right
both of those are equally like valuable
parts of myself right it's just
different energies that are expressed at
different times the masculine and the
feminine side and people have different
levels of them some are more masculine
and some are more feminine and they
fulfill that role it doesn't it's not
determined by biological sex it's just
not it can be
but it's it's it's gender is a construct
right and we have different degrees of
masculine and feminine energies in us
you probably have more masculine and
that's fine but other people men
especially do have more feminine energy
and there shouldn't be a judgment on
that everyone has their role in society
everywhere has their place i also think
it's way more accepted if you're a
masculine woman
in society because masculinity is so
like valued and revered but if you're a
bit of a feminine man yeah you're a
[ __ ] or aurora where it's like actually
that's fine like you can you can also
i think it's it's it's accepted yeah
it's it's it's
it's it's it's accepted by other women
but it's not accepted by men do you know
what they have their if their job is not
going to be feminine
and then they match i mean typically
typically the guys that typically the
guys that like masculine women are are
usually
males they're usually yeah like i mean
the girls don't even like him
the girls like it's like those girls
that hate their husbands because they
have him by the balls
like this is what and i know you're
thinking to someone but why are we
creating femininity with like being
submissive
and being like
there's nothing wrong with that